ending a 49-year long Union the
announcement was made live and
simultaneously on the national
televisions of ner Burkina Faso and Mali
the three countries are withdrawing from
the West African Regional block known as
echos which includes all 16 West African
nations the organization imposed
sanctions against the three nations
after their militaries took power in a
coup in recent years echas is calling
for a return to civil Rule The Joint
decision to leave the union is an act of
defiance by the military junas in the
face of sanctions that limit border
movements and the ability to trade
hurting the country's already vulnerable
economies echas allegedly adopted an
irrational and unacceptable stance by
imposing sanctions that were illegal
illegitimate inhumane and irresponsible
in violation of its own
statutes created in 1975 the econ e omic
community of West African States was
intended to bring closer economic ties
prevent military coups and protect
democracy critics now see it as a club
for corrupt and aging African leaders
clinging to power out of touch with the
aspiration of their young population and
influenced by the
West if our people say we want to be
governed by a military man why are we
going to refuse them is it Echo us that
comes give us food does Echo us pay our
soldiers and why should it have a say in
how we govern
ourselves last September the gentle
leaders of the three nations signed a
mutual defense pact they call the Sahel
State Alliance it commits each country
to come to the other's defense if their
territorial integrities threaten both
from internal and external forces many
in this region say this is an important
issue the West African block has failed
to address for the leaders the needs of
Mali ner and binaso feels ignored by
echas it is a relationship they no
longer want to be a part of Nicholas
Hawk Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer